from the moment she was born
from the moment i was pregnant with her
i have had this giant burden of
i'm the only one that cares for her
that's kind of been a recurring theme is
like wow if i don't figure this out
who will
i'm pregnant oh god it could happen to
any one of you it could have been any of
them girls get pregnant in high school
i'm not like everybody else in high
school
[Music]
i became a mom a little over three years
ago at 17 years old
i became a teen mom at the age of 14.
i was 16 when i became a dad so i was
18. it was actually right out of high
school
at first it was very hard but you know i
promised that i was going to be
be there for her the most annoying
stereotype about being a teen mom was
definitely
that i'm not going to make it and that
my daughter's life will be
less than because i'm so young when i
tell people in my class oh i have a
child they're like oh like
they assume that i don't know as much as
them because i i guess i made the
decision to have a child young
a lot of people assume because you have
a child your life is completely over but
they're wrong
[Music]
hi my name is joanna i am a mother to
esmeralda platero she's two years old
i'm ali um i'm a single mom of a little
girl
uh so my name is ednan and i'm a father
to a beautiful little girl
in gwendolyn hi my name is brandon i
have a two-year-old son named isaiah
i'm currently working like three jobs
and i just graduated
high school wow congratulations right
please walk forward if you agree with
the statement
i wish i had children later
you know this i feel like this question
is really hard because all right off the
bat people are gonna assume oh
like you don't you know you don't love
your daughter or something but like i i
do i love
you know my child with all my heart and
everything i have to give i'll do
anything for her
but you know i had the option you know
she'll be the exact same
everything but half her later i would
definitely choose to have her later i
mean it just
to get everything situated to you know
just set everything up to provide
that for her i would definitely you know
recommend do it later do when we're not
children
when we're older and have more insight i
agree with you there it's like from a
logistical standpoint
it makes a lot more sense to have money
in the bank
and to have support and to have a
celebrated pregnancy and have a partner
in
a house all these things that you
typically would
although the same in the same token it's
we're so happy we're so in love we've
learned so much and being a parent is so
much
of who we are
me looking back i'm i'm happy i'm really
extremely happy that i decided to
have my child you know i was extremely
comfortable with keeping my child
because i knew that
not only would she heal me but i would
be able to give her love that i was just
eagerly willing to like give to somebody
but of course
deserving you know it helps you mentally
you just yeah it makes you comfortable
and it just makes you happy
just you know knowing that you're
raising this kid and
you know make you feel proud of yourself
yes i wouldn't change something but in
that moment
when we're a young teenager about to go
after college like we just got out of
high school you know our life is just
beginning
i didn't have that hindsight i'm i
didn't have that
oh it'll it'll work it's it's scary
financially socially everywhere and
if i was in that spot i think i would
say yes i would definitely want
to have it later in life and i mean if
but yeah hindsight i carry more of the
burden of supporting my child
than my partner
i'm sorry that's all i want to say i'm
sorry that you're here
she doesn't work right now but you know
but she does help
in a different way by taking care of him
right
but it's mostly me making the money and
it's mostly her
taking care of my child it's a hard
thing to feel like the whole financial
burden is on you
because it just innate something in you
and you're like oh my gosh if i don't
bring money home for my child what's
going to happen
and that's scary when colbot hit
actually
i've been laid off like twice so that
there was a point
in my life where i wasn't making no
money it was difficult finding a job
that time and i felt very unappreciated
i kind of have the stereotypical story
of being young
and pregnant and her dad wanting to kind
of live his life and
his family really supported him wanting
to live his life
and i felt so much guilt and shame
for wishing that he wanted to be around
more when she was younger he's grown
into it
a lot which is really great and i'm so
thankful for that but
from the moment she was born from the
moment i was pregnant with her
i have had this giant burden of i'm the
only one that cares for her
that's kind of been a recurring theme is
like wow if i don't figure this out
who will and it's a scary feeling but
it's also the most beautiful thing
because we've become just
this symbiotic relationship between me
and her and
i just know her so well i know
everything about her and i'm happy
it's just crazy how fast we matured
yeah and you look at our you know
friends that we have and you know
they're
a little bit more immature to selflessly
serve someone
will bring out wisdom in anyone because
you're putting yourself last
i was really in between disagreeing and
agreeing
from the beginning of you know the
pregnancy to now
majority of that whole time frame i was
the one putting like 80 percent
of you know responsibility i was buying
everything
i was literally i didn't ask him for
anything i was
it felt like i was a single parent he
would uh spend time with our daughter
but that's not just that's simply just
not enough you know i got an offer for
modeling in
january and so i had to leave my state
and i had to leave my daughter behind
with my family
and her father which is the hardest
thing i ever had to do
the responsibility of my daughter is now
like basically equal
we still live in different households
we're still separate
um at the moment until we're saving up
for um
we can get a place together i see her
every day everything we're together all
the time
when i have to leave at night and she
doesn't get that opportunity
to leave she's with if she gets up at
night she has to be with her so i feel
like that burden
definitely she she has more
responsibility in that aspect and then
she is with her more often because i do
have a lot more
sponsors with school when working but
she's also doing school and work
so it's just it's really it's all it's a
roller coaster ride sometimes i wanted
to ask
like you know you being a team father i
feel like people automatically assume
that you put in less work
so when you tell people you are a team
parent do they assume
or how does that go like i mean when
usually when people ask me if i'm a team
friend it's usually when i'm with my son
so i'm like oh all right are you is this
is this your brother no that's my kid
and they you know oh okay oh yeah right
babysitter
are you do you have availability
literally that's the worst one
no this is my kid this is my you know
this is me for me just depends on the
context like and i'm not there they ask
my fiance oh
he's a father not in the relationship i
think it's just a stereotype now that
you know the dad usually leaves and
responsibly falls on the mother
my mental health was heavily impacted
since becoming a parent
i'm trying to think of how to articulate
this because it's it's a wide range of
emotions i feel like it's not only being
scared
you got anxiety from oh i have to
support my child am i doing this right
doing this
and it definitely keeps you up at night
and i was never a good sleeper
as is it really did take its toll
whether it be like my social
um how i interacted with like my
girlfriend get kind of
more irritable i guess but until i found
that balance
i come from a divorced family so i feel
like there was different
groups of people that i needed to tell
and the first
two people that we told it was a really
horrible reaction
it was slamming on the table it was
tears
i was in tears i
i just wanted to disappear i just wanted
to not exist they were talking about
every option
besides keeping her and it was very
sneaky and deceptive and under the table
like hey we can do something
behind the scenes i went through the
same thing yeah
as a woman like as a girl too like a
pregnant girl you just so
your whole brain chemistry changes when
you're pregnant you're on protect mode
you're on try to make everyone happy
mode
and it's really weird i think loneliness
is one of the most scary
detrimental things that people can go
through for their mental health
it just can be so painful and when
you're young you're a young parent
it just feels like no one could
understand what you're going through
you need people it takes a village to
raise children is such a great quote and
it's so true
i wanted so badly to be able to do it on
my own and prove everyone wrong
and it was that moment i surrendered
that pride and i'm like no it takes
people to pour in
to me and to her and to love on her and
help me do this
asking for help can be one of the
strongest things you can do i've
basically
been like a sad person since i was a
little little girl
about like the age of nine i started you
know having depression
and being suicidal in middle school i
actually was
admitted into a mental hospital because
i try to
like commit suicide and that was
literally right before my freshman year
before i got pregnant and
my mindset was i was still depressed you
know
my household and the people who were in
my life were very very extremely toxic
and abusive so when i felt pregnant
it was more it was like i call her my
lifesaver i truly do because
like she really i don't know where i
would be i don't even think i would be
on this earth
if i if i didn't fall pregnant like i
literally felt pregnant at 14.
i had to go to school with my baby
father at that time
he was not claiming the child so i
literally saw him in the hallways every
day you know with my
big belly you know i would be crying
like
every single night so i didn't really
have anybody support
but so you want to give the child your
the happiness that you didn't have
exactly but every time i look down at my
stomach i was just like
i'll do this for you and i know i know
that you're gonna give me the love that
i wish
i was raised with you know and i will
give you the love because you deserve it
and that's what really took me off
and i started just becoming the woman
that i'm supposed to be for my daughter
and for myself you know so
yeah i did it
i also grew up in a bad childhood you
know my parents were also team parents
so they were on and off for like 10
years and my dad would
will get very domestic with my mother
and how to you know
go through that how to watch that and i
had to go i had to see my mom's pain
so i was also very depressed i was um
you know i was also suicidal when you
know i found out that
she was pregnant and i was you know to
be honest i was embarrassed
you know like i would get where i live
you know i would get clowned on you know
hey
you know you got that girl pregnant and
but i decided not to look at it as a
negative thing
but more more of a positive thing okay
well i have something i have a
motivation that
all the all these people don't have what
the situation i had with my ex with the
mother of my child
with my baby mama um you know
i noticed that there was those red flags
i saw from my childhood
that i don't want for my son i don't
want him to see that and my goal is
to break the cycle i don't want my kid
being a teen parent so i'm gonna
make sure he's taught well because i i
never had
a father figure that taught me about sex
about
using condoms i think we can all agree
that it's very hard to tell our parents
that we you know we were pregnant or we
gotta go pregnant
for me when i saw my mom you know me
knowing that she was also a teen mom
oh man she went crazy she started
throwing stuff
late spots or dodging like the matrix i
was like
i got very lucky at the time that i told
her like i think
if i because she was a teen parent all
she had to be very young and
she had sacrificed a lot of her life to
make sure that i had the opportunity she
didn't have
i found it just like a slap in the face
to her i feel like that was gonna be the
hardest person to tell
because you had worked your all your
adult life to
prevent this from happening to give me
make sure i get a good education don't
repeat the cycle for me just to go back
and repeat the cycle
she just wanted to provide me with that
network so it wasn't as hard you know so
i can finish what i was doing and
provide for my daughter and just
have access to these opportunities still
so i'm definitely very grateful
there are goals i've had to sacrifice
since becoming a parent
well since i had my my daughter right
out of high school
i don't have the opportunity
to pursue like a legal education maybe i
wanted to have done because i've gotten
you know offers from schools out of
state like oh here's we can give you
scholarships
but obviously i'm not going to take them
because i my family is here and this is
where we're rooted
when i found out i was going to be i was
going to become a father
i didn't really have any goals i didn't
know what i was going to do
but i was going to pursue it pursue as a
career military was an option
i was looking into becoming enlisted in
the air force
but in order to do that i had to give up
all my custody to the grandmother since
my baby mom is a minor she's 17 right
now so
it kind of got me stuck because that was
my
my goal to join the military
educationally i was always striving like
i was always on the honors role
and so when i got to high school i got
the opportunity to graduate early even
having my child
you know but because at that time i was
such
just into just being with my child 24 7.
i didn't trust
anybody around my child like me going
away to college especially in another
state
no like i can't i couldn't do that i had
to
sacrifice that but it was not much of a
sacrifice to me it was more of a
sacrifice to my
family that's the way they saw it you
know you know after you have a child
your mentality changes and you really
start caring about what makes you happy
and makes a child happy
all of my goals and dreams changed
when i had her so it wasn't like i was
sacrificing anyway i didn't feel
like i was throwing opportunities in the
trash
so when i had my daughter it was this
complete shift as soon as i got pregnant
that wow
it was a come to jesus moment your life
is not about you anymore
quite literally you there's two of you
now
and it was such a humbling spiritual
experience
once i just felt that love and knew i
would do anything for her
and you see this hope in their little
eyes
and they're like a blank piece of paper
just ready to have a story rewritten
a beautiful story and you get to be a
part of it and it's just
so cool it's not even like you're in
control as a parent you realize how
little control
you have and how you're just kind of
along for the ride
so being a team parent is not it's not
bad it's actually
a benefit it's actually a benefit
i would still i don't know if i'd
recommend it i wouldn't recommend it
[Music]
yes
you